[Music]
if I take a night off people get hurt
you don't get where's your wound by they
take it by fools I think that this world
needs men that I'm willing to make the
hard way
I'm isn't gonna change who I am or what
I do
excited and honored to be a part of the
show it's a character that means a lot
to a lot of people I'm excited for
people to see Jon Bernthal and the young
thing these iconic roles and it just
kind of escalates from there there's
nothing
well I'll just say this is going to be
action-packed from beginning to the very
end trust me
daredevil premieres March 18th and I
will see the fans on September 3rd
hey youtubers it's Charlie so we have
t-minus 1 week before daredevil season 2
gets here so this is just gonna be a
breakdown of what's going on and some
recommended reading I love the idea of
the daredevil cast picking team cap team
Ironman if you've never read Marvel
Civil War event Punisher technically
tried to join team cap but they thought
he was too crazy spider-man had a big
falling-out with Iron Man got his ass
handed to him when he was still in the
iron spider suit Punisher found him
brought him to team cap and was like hey
I'm here and they're like ok dude thanks
but no thanks you just leave him right
here and you be away on your business
you're away too crazy for us even if we
do love the fact that you hate Iron Man
even though he was part of the military
for a long time he has become
anti-establishment so automatically in a
street war he's gonna open fire on
anyone who he deems to be the man and
the man of daredevil season 2 isn't so
much the kingpin as it is the hand if
you're big comic book fan which I
imagine most of you are and you want to
read something that's gonna tie in with
daredevil season 2 the closest thing is
gonna be daredevil versus Punisher there
isn't any straight-up comic book that
they adapted season 2 is really like
this logical extension of what happened
during season 1 they just tease the hand
they tease black sky they tease this
giant mystical plot they're probably
gonna try and raise the demon is what I
imagine in the ongoing war between the
chased in the hand the chased is the
organization that stick belongs to but
we really haven't learned about that in
the daredevil university yet we just got
teasers for that in season 1 the
interesting thing that I wasn't
expecting but I probably should have is
the tag line they've been using is that
it's going to take all three of them to
save Hell's Kitchen which means that no
matter how much they're at each other's
throats throughout the series they're
gonna come together in some form by the
end and really daredevil is the only one
you could call it superhero Elektra and
Punisher more anti-heroes than they are
heroes because they cause just as much
collateral damage as they do help people
if you want to read a good Elektra story
and you don't know anything about her
character actually man without fear is
probably a good title to read that
original Frank Miller story that's the
story that introduced her and it was the
story they used for a lot of season one
from daredevil but they just they cut
the Elektra part out they withheld her
till season 2 there are some comics that
have explained her backstory like
Elektra assassin but that's a little
trickier the artwork
that made it look like the artist did a
whole bunch of drugs before he did it so
if you really like trippy comics it's a
lot of fun but if you like comics that
look a little more mainstream just stick
to the Frank Miller stuff and if you're
a hardcore Punisher fan and you just
want to read more Punisher Punisher War
Journal is a good comic to read if you
guys are big fans of Jim Lee's artwork
that was the comic that he got started
on the comic that got him the x-men
number one job the x-men title that sold
more copies than any comic book in
history I think it was like 8.1 million
copies
but like I said they didn't really take
any comic book stories and adapt them
for season two they just borrowed a lot
of the characters and a lot of the
aesthetic of some of these comic books
and yes I know we haven't seen them in
any of the teasers
but kingpin will totally be around it's
just that the hand is the biggest
villain this season the hand versus
Hell's Kitchen let me know in the
comments though what are you guys most
hype about for season 2 I feel like for
most of us it's the Punisher I mean I'm
wearing my Punisher t-shirt right now in
the bummer is is that they keep trying
to downplay the idea of a spin-off
Punisher series they'll still do it at
some point what they've said is that
it's just not their first priority right
now speaking of other series they did
confirm that Luke Cage is going to drop
September 30th now I say premiere but
they're gonna dump the entire series so
you'll be able to watch every single
episode all 13 of them
September 30th sweet Christmas in
September what's gonna happen next week
is that my daredevil episode videos will
start posting on Friday and if you saw
my Jessica Jones videos I did like one
video for every three episodes that's
probably what I'm gonna do for daredevil
like I can't do 13 videos in like two
days so be sure to subscribe to get
everything it is gonna be awesome you
guys have no idea how awesome the
Punisher is gonna be Elektra is gonna be
a lot of fun too but really it's the
Punisher that I'm excited for there's
supposedly some new Captain America
Civil War footage that's dropping later
tonight if there is I'll totally do a
video for it I'm also working on a Game
of Thrones video so I'll be posting
updates on which video is posting when
on Facebook and Twitter if you don't
know where to find me there the links
are at the bottom of the description it
is gonna be so awesome next week you
guys have no idea why you wait for my
next video to post you can click here
for my Captain America civil war trailer
and you can click here for all my other
daredevil season 2 videos thank you so
much for watching everybody
sigh five I'll see you guys tonight
you